It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在正值授粉高峰期，我的业务规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢再忙碌，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这绝对是一个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需另付税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Right now is a stressful time for many American workers. Employees across job sectors are worried about growing economic uncertainty, major shifts in government policy, and the looming question of how artificial intelligence will change the workplace. In fact, according to APA's latest work in America survey, more than half of U.S. workers, 54%, say that job insecurity is causing them stress. So how does all this uncertainty affect people's mental,
Google Fi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不会受到数据流量降速的影响。对许多美国劳动者来说，现在是一个压力重重的时期。各行各业的雇员都在担心不断加剧的经济不确定性、政府政策的重大转变，以及人工智能将如何改变职场这一迫在眉睫的问题。事实上，根据美国心理学协会（APA）最新发布的“美国工作现状”调查，超过半数（54%）的美国劳动者表示，工作的不安全感正给他们带来压力。那么，所有这些不确定性是如何影响人们的心理、
and even physical health? How does it affect their relationships and their life inside and outside of work? What can people do to build resilience in the face of job uncertainty? And what can employers and organizations do to foster well-being and stability even in these uncertain times? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
甚至生理健康的呢？它又是如何影响他们的关系以及工作内外的生活的？面对工作的不确定性，人们可以做些什么来增强适应力？在这些不确定时期，雇主和组织又能做些什么来促进福祉和稳定性呢？欢迎收看《心理学热线》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，专门探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
My guest today is Dr. Mindy Shoss, a professor of psychology at the University of Central Florida. Her research focuses on the intersection of occupational health psychology and the future of work, including such topics as job insecurity and precarious work, the integration of artificial intelligence and robotics in the workplace, worker well-being, and adaptation to change. She's a fellow of the Society for Industrial and Organizational Psychology and sits on APA's Future of Work Advisory, Committee. She's been interviewed by media outlets, including the New York Times, the Wall Street
我今天的嘉宾是中佛罗里达大学（University of Central Florida）心理学教授明迪·肖斯博士（Dr. Mindy Shoss）。她的研究重点是职业健康心理学与未来工作之间的交集，包括工作不安全感与不稳定的工作、人工智能和机器人技术在职场中的整合、员工福祉以及对变化的适应等课题。她是工业与组织心理学协会（Society for Industrial and Organizational Psychology）的会士，并担任美国心理学协会未来工作咨询委员会的成员。她曾就未来工作和员工福祉等话题接受过《纽约时报》、《华尔街日报》、BBC 和《华盛顿邮报》等媒体的采访。肖斯博士，非常感谢您今天能做客节目。谢谢邀请我。我想从我在引言中提到的美国心理学协会调查数据开始，该数据显示 54% 的人表示工作不安全感正在给他们带来压力并产生重大影响。从您作为一名长期研究工作不安全感的学者的角度来看，现在对劳动者来说是否是一个特别不稳定和充满压力的时期？不幸的是，调查结果与我们在调查和研究数据中看到的情况不谋而合。现在确实是一个特别不确定的时期，因为多种事件交织在了一起，
Journal, the BBC, and the Washington Post about the future of work and worker well-being. Dr. Shoss, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me. I'd like to start with the APA survey data that I mentioned in the introduction, which found that 54% of people are saying that job insecurity is causing them stress and having a significant an impact. From your perspective, as someone who has studied job and security for quite a while, does now seem like a particularly unstable and stressful time for workers. Unfortunately, the survey finding drives with what we're seeing in our survey and research data as well. And now is a particularly uncertain time because there's really a confluence of events
这些事件不仅威胁着人们的工作，也让人们有机会退后一步，评估一下自己目前的工作状况，从而引发了极大的担忧。首先，关于企业裁员的头条新闻层出不穷。我们在疫情期间肯定见过了这种情况，但在过去一两年里我们也同样看到了这一点，尤其是在科技行业，不过其他行业也纷纷效仿。就在本周，新闻头条上充斥着家喻户晓的知名企业裁员的消息，比如宝洁、微软、沃尔玛。当人们听到裁员的消息时，他们就会开始担心自己的工作和自己所在的公司。
that are both threatening people's jobs, but also giving people, sort of opportunity to take a step back, try to evaluate what's going on in their own job situation, and it's creating a lot of concern. So first, there's been constant headlines about corporate layoffs. Certainly we saw this during the pandemic, but we've also seen this over the last year or two, particularly in the technology sector, but other sectors have also followed suit. Even this week, There are headlines of layoffs at household names, companies that are household names, Procter Gamble, Microsoft, Walmart. And when people hear about layoffs, they start worrying about their own job and their own company.
当然，正如你在引言中提到的那样，另一个因素是作为一项快速发展的技术，人工智能的兴起。你知道，劳动者们有充分的理由对此感到担忧，即人工智能将如何被应用到劳动力队伍中，以及它将对人们寻找和保住优质工作的能力产生什么影响。正如你所提到的，第三个因素实际上是政府裁员。不仅政府雇员受到了影响，各行各业、各种与政府做生意或依赖政府伙伴关系开展工作的组织中的雇员也都受到了影响。正如美国心理学协会在最新“美国工作”调查中所报告的那样，我们看到了这种连锁反应。那么，你在研究中是如何定义和衡量工作不安全感的呢？
Of course, another factor, as you mentioned in the introduction, is the emergence of AI as a rapidly developing technology. And, you know, there's a lot of concern out there, rightfully so, from workers, about how AI is going to get implemented into the workforce and what the implications are going to be for people's ability to find and hold on to good quality jobs. And a third factor, as you mentioned, is really the government layoffs. Not only government employees have been impacted, but also employees at all sorts of workers. organizations that do business with government or rely on government partnerships for their work. And we see the ripple effects as APA just reported in the most recent work in America's survey. Now, how do you define and measure job insecurity in your research?
因此，我们通常通过让人们报告他们对被解雇和失业的担忧程度来衡量工作不安全感。对个人感知和担忧的关注，使我们坚定地处于理解人们如何感知威胁的心理学传统之中。甚至还有这样一个项目，由我的一位刚毕业的博士生领导。我们发现，人们可能会对自己的工作安全感感到极大的担忧，即使他们认为自己实际被解雇的可能性相对较低。这是因为工作对人们来说真的非常非常重要。它们在我们的生活中扮演着许多角色，无论是在经济上还是在心理上。所以，你知道，我们发现对于那些觉得可能很难找到同等质量另一份工作的人来说，情况尤其如此，这一点我想美国心理学协会最近的调查也指出来了，当时他们实际分解了数据，并关注了那些担心失业的劳动者，以及担心能否找到能替代它的另一份工作的担忧。工作不安全感是如何影响人们的身心健康的呢？所以，工作不安全感被认为是职场中的一个主要压力源，我们在文献中一次又一次地看到了这一点。原因可以追溯到我刚才所说的话，
So we commonly measure job insecurity by asking people to report the extent to which they're worried about being laid off and losing their jobs. And the focus on individuals' perceptions and worries kind of places us squarely in the psychological tradition of understanding how people perceive threats. And even there's a project led by one of my now graduated doctoral students. And we found that people may experience significant worries about their job security, even if they think there's a relatively low likelihood that they would be actually laid off. And this is because jobs are really, really important to people. They play a lot of roles in our lives, both financially and psychologically. And so, you know, we found this to be particularly
就在刚才，因为工作在人们的生活中极其重要。因此，工作决定了你赚取的收入、你在哪里以及如何生活，工作提供了一种身份认同感、意义感以及与他人的联系，并为我们的时间和生活提供了结构。还要记住，医疗保健、退休计划等各项事务都与拥有一份工作息息相关。因此，当工作悬而未决、充满不确定性时，人们所有的这些基本需求也就同样悬而未决。因此，毫无疑问，你会发现在文献中，工作不安全感被发现与身心健康的损害息息相关。我的同事考特·鲁道夫（Court Rudolph）、哈尼西克（Honeysik）和我刚刚发表了一项纵向分析。
the case for people who felt like it might be harder to find another job of the same quality, which again, I think APA surveys also recently pointed to when they actually broke down the data and looked at workers who are concerned about losing their job, as well as concerns about being able to find another job that could replace it. How does job insecurity affect people's physical and mental health? So job insecurity is considered to be a major workplace stressor, and we see this again and again in the literature. And the reason why goes back to what I was saying,
我们拥有 33 波特定的月度数据，其中人们会报告他们的工作安全感以及身心健康状况。我们发现，这实际上是一个负面放大循环：工作不安全感损害了心理健康，然后心理健康水平的下降又进一步加剧了对工作安全的担忧。我们认为，这一发现有助于解释，
a moment ago because jobs are tremendously important in people's lives. So jobs determine the income you earn, where, how you live, jobs provide a sense of identity and meaning and connection with others and give structure to our time and our lives. Also keep in mind that things like health care, retirement plans, all these things are connected to having a job. So when the job is up in the air and it's uncertain, all these basic needs that people have are also up in the air. So not surprisingly, you'll see that job insecurity is found in the lurcher to be associated with harms to physical and mental health. Colleagues of mine, Court Rudolph, Honeysik, and I just published a longitudinal analysis.
为什么工作不安全感一直被发现是一个如此有害的压力源。我很想知道工作不安全感对工作质量和生产力有什么影响。我的意思是，如果你的老板在谈论裁员的可能性，这会激励员工表现得更好以免被解雇，还是会让他们在工作中的效率降低？我很高兴你问了这个问题，因为我认为这里存在很多误解。简短的回答是，不，工作不安全感对绩效毫无帮助。因此，人们当然希望保住工作，他们也有动力这样做，但这并不一定能转化为更好的表现。因此，我和其他实验室的研究发现，
We had 33 waves of certain monthly data where people would report their job security and their physical and mental health. And what we found was that there's really a negative amplifying cycle where job insecurity harms mental health, then decreases in mental health, further contribute to concerns about job security. And we think that this finding helps explain.
相反，工作不安全感会导致表演型行为。例如，试图表现得很忙，会导致竞争行为、试图在其他人面前占得先机，以及由于人们确实感到害怕而产生的恐惧驱动行为。这不利于绩效、创新，也不利于我们在思考工作绩效时所期望的所有其他类型的事情。那么，什么才是有帮助的呢？有哪些因素能让员工在工作中表现得更好？当然。因此，当人们有一定的安全感时，当没有压倒性的压力分散注意力或损害有损工作绩效的福祉时，他们的表现往往会更好。当人们感到受到支持、充满活力、被赋能去真正尝试新事物、产生积极影响并追求组织的目标时。
why job insecurity continues to be found to be such a pernicious stressor. I'm wondering what effect job insecurity has on work quality and productivity. I mean, if your boss is talking about the possibility of layoffs, does that motivate employees to perform better so that they won't be let go or does it make them less effective at their job? I'm really glad you asked this question because I think there's a lot of of misconceptions here. And the short answer is, no, job and security is not helpful for performance. So people certainly want to keep their jobs, and they're motivated to do so, but that doesn't necessarily translate into performing better. So research from my lab and others has found that
所以这些事情，这些事情才是有帮助的，而不是裁员的威胁。人们会习惯职场中的不确定性吗，还是说它总是充满压力？例如，假设某人长期做自由职业者，与一个以前在某个目前正经历快速变革的领域拥有稳定工作的人相比呢？当然，这是一个很好的问题。而且我认为在几个方面，文献中对这个问题仍未完全解答。不过，欧洲有一组研究人员，尼莉·迪克·奎珀（Neely De Cuyper）和汉斯·德维特（Hans DeWitt），他们一直在比较临时合同工和永久合同工对工作不安全感的反应。
job insecurity instead leads to performative behaviors. So, for example, trying to look busy, leads to competitive behaviors, trying to get a step up on others, and really fear-based behaviors because people are really afraid. And that's not good for performance or innovation or all the other types of things that we hope for when we think about performance at work. Well, what is helpful? What are the factors that will make people perform better at their jobs? Sure. So people actually tend to perform better when they have some sense of security, when there's not an overwhelming amount of stress that's distracting attention or well-being that detracts from job performance. And when people feel supported and energized and empowered to really try things and to try to have a positive impact and pursue the goals of the organization.
我认为他们得出的普遍结论是，虽然对于那些本身就不安全的临时合同工来说，工作不安全感对期望的违背程度较小，但在福祉和工作满意度方面，工作不安全感仍然是一种具有挑战性的体验。所以你可以这样想。作为人类，我们喜欢预测和控制生活中的重要方面，而不确定性威胁到了我们这样做的能力。话虽如此，长期处于这些职位的人可能已经采用了各种策略，
So those things, those things are helpful, not the threat of layoffs. Do people get used to uncertainty in the workplace, or is it always stressful? For example, say someone's been a long-time freelancer versus someone with a previously stable job in a field that's now undergoing rapid change? Sure, this is a great question. And I think in several ways it's still somewhat unanswered. answered in the literature. However, there's a team of researchers in Europe, Neely Dick Kuyper and Hans DeWitt, who've been comparing reactions to job insecurity amongst workers
来帮助他们度过不确定的时期。但这并不一定意味着不确定性对他们来说就不是一种压力源。劳动者能做些什么呢，那些感到压力和不确定的人，他们可以做些什么来应对？有什么策略可以用来增强他们的适应力，无论是在职场内还是职场外？这是一个很好的问题，因为正如你所报道的美国心理学协会调查显示的那样，许多人正在经历工作不安全感。
with temporary or permanent contracts. And I think the general conclusion that they found is that while job insecurity is less of a violation of expectations amongst those who have inherently insecure, temperate contracts, job insecurity is still a challenging experience in terms of just well-being and in job satisfaction. And so you might think of it this way. As human beings, we like to predict and control important aspects of our lives, and uncertainty threatens our ability to do that. That said, people have been in these positions for a long time, have probably adopted strategies
因此，采取各种策略来应对这种体验将变得非常重要。因此，有些策略——我想我们现在在各种领英（LinkedIn）帖子或其他地方都能看到这一点——就是记住，作为一个人的你，不仅仅是一份单一的工作。因此，人们在生活中扮演着各种角色。他们拥有身份的各个不同切面。所有这些都很重要。试着去肯定、铭记并参与到你作为一个人的不同自我中去，可以帮助应对伴随工作不安全感而来的部分威胁。
to help them manage uncertain periods. But that doesn't necessarily mean that the uncertainty is not a stressor for them. What can workers do, those who are feeling stressed and uncertain, what can they do to cope? But there's strategies that they can use to build their resilience, both in the workplace and outside of it? That's a great question, because as you reported in the APA survey shows, many people are experiencing job insecurity.
此外，当时代感到非常不确定时，总是试着去思考，好吧，哪些是你能控制的事情，哪些是你无法控制的事情。或者说你可能需要什么信息来帮助做出决定，试着非常具体地专注于你能控制的事情或你需要的信息可能会有所帮助。当然，也有一些关于培养技能、制定备用计划的建议。我认为在应对不确定时期时，所有这些都可能有所帮助。但同时也要记住人们曾经克服过困难的时刻。
So it's going to become really important to engage a variety of strategies to try to cope with this experience. So some strategies, and I think we all see this on various LinkedIn posts or things right now, is just remembering that you as a person are more than just a single job. So people hold various roles in life. They have various pieces of your identity. And all of those are important. And trying to affirm and remember and engage with those different parts of who you are as a person can help manage some of the threat that comes with job insecurity.
伴随着不确定性。因此，我们所有人都在生活中面临过各种不确定时期，记住那些你不知道会发生什么或事情悬而未决但你最终挺过来了的时刻，会很有帮助。在我们做过的一些研究中，我们发现把自己想象成一个有复原力的人，能够从事件中恢复过来，并试图寻找创造性的方法来处理困难情况，这有助于抵消工作不安全感的一些负面影响。我们将进行短暂的休息，回来后我们将与肖斯博士探讨，在面对不确定性和变化的组织中，雇主可以做些什么来提升员工福祉。
Also, when times feel very uncertain, always trying to think about, okay, what are the things you can control and one of the things that you can't control. and or what is the information that you might need to help make a decision, trying to focus very concretely on what you can control or what information you need might help. There's also some certainly advice on developing skills, creating a backup plan. I think all of those are probably helpful when dealing with periods of uncertainty. But also remembering that times that people have COVID. with uncertainty. So all of us have faced various periods of uncertainty in our lives and remembering
你是否曾经重新摆放过家具，然后发现下面的地毯看起来像是崭新的，而其余部分看起来……嗯，没那么新？是时候升级地毯了。在家得宝（The Home Depot），我们以实惠的价格提供来自各大顶级品牌的时尚选择。最棒的是，我们可以为你安装，每平方英尺仅需 0.49 美元起。所以你只需挑选你完美的地板。今天就在家得宝开始你的地毯项目吧。实干者成就更多。
times where you didn't know what was going to happen or things were up in the air and you dealt with it can be helpful. In some research we've done, we found that sort of thinking of yourself as a resilient person who bounces back from events, who tries to look for creative ways to deal with difficult situations, can be helpful in counteracting some of the negative. effects of job and security. We're going to take a short break, and when we return, we'll talk with Dr. Shoss about what employers can do to increase well-being in organizations that are facing uncertainty and change.
许可证适用除外条款，请参阅 Home Depot.com 上的许可证号。你曾说过这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步在哪。我们省了多少钱？够了。够到迷失方向。或者你可以预订希尔顿的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水边仅数步之遥。
Have you ever rearranged your furniture and discovered the carpet underneath looks brand new, while the rest of it looks, well, not so new? It's time for a carpet upgrade. At the Home Depot, we have stylish choices at simple prices from all the top brands. Best of all, we can install it for you, starting at only $0.49 per square foot. So all you have to do is pick your perfect floor. Start your carpet project today at the Home Depot. How doers get more done.
希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，即可享受最高 20% 的优惠，获得你期望的住宿体验。当你想要的是节省，而不是惊吓。住哪里，至关重要。希尔顿，有位有留。在这种情况下，雇主的角色是什么？他们可以做些什么来提升员工的福祉，尤其是在目前可能正面临不确定性和变革的组织中？所以，我有一个好朋友是系统工程师，她曾对我说过，在流程中存在着确定性。我认为这是真的。我认为虽然工作不安全感和不确定性会带来压力，但组织可以通过做出清晰透明的决策、就决策进行沟通、展现公平、处理谣言以及总体上（你知道的）传达计划，来帮助减少压力和不确定性。
Exclusions apply for licenses see Home Depot.com slash license numbers. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
这就是我们将作为组织前进的方式，展现出他们重视员工。甚至在我们的研究中，我们发现管理者只要积极倾听员工的担忧，就能实际减少人们对工作不安全感的感知，并增强他们的控制感。如果这种做法是在个人层面上进行的（就像你刚才提到的管理者），效果会更好吗？还是说如果它来自首席执行官、董事会（你知道的，组织高层），帮助会更大？我认为以上皆是，因为在不确定时期，心理学研究表明人们有寻找信息的需要。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. What's the role of employers in this case? What can they do to increase work or well-being, especially in organizations that might be facing uncertainty and change right now? So I have a good friend who's a systems engineer, and she told me once that there's certainty in process. And I think that's true. I think while job insecurity and certainty is stressful, organizations can help reduce stress and uncertainty by making clear and transparent decisions, by communicating about decisions, by demonstrating fairness, by addressing rumors, and by generally, you know, communicating plans.
所以他们在寻找信息。他们在寻找确定性。他们在寻找对即将发生事情的最佳猜测。而且他们的搜寻范围很广。因此，即使组织本身没有面临任何直接威胁或没有裁员计划，仅仅听到其他组织进行裁员的消息，就会让人们担心自己的工作，并可能产生谣言之类的事情。因此，我认为各个层面都需要解决这样一个事实：我们目前生活在一个不确定时期，许多人对工作的未来确实感到压力和担忧。最近我听到很多人在谈论有毒职场。
This is how we're going to move forward as an organization that show that they value their people. Even in our research, we found that managers just actively listening to employees' concerns actually decrease people's perceptions of job insecurity and increase their sense of control. And is that better for people if it's happening on an individual level, like you just mentioned managers, or does it help more if it's coming from the CEO, the board, you know, people at the top of the organization? I think all the above, because in times of uncertainty, psychological research shows that people have a need to find information.
我认为这个词有一个非常特定的含义。什么构成了有毒职场，雇主又该如何防范这种环境的产生？因此，当我想到有毒职场时，我想到的职场是由恐惧所定义的，或者说恐惧定义了职场中的人际关系。它是文化的一个决定性方面。它是政策和实践如何被实施和执行的一个决定性方面。那么，雇主该如何防范有毒职场的产生呢？
So they're looking for information. They're looking for certainty. They're looking for best guesses of what's going to happen. And they look widely. So even if the organization itself is not facing any immediate threats or doesn't have plans for layoffs, Just hearing about other organizations engaging in layoffs can make people worried about their own jobs and it could create rumors and things like that. So I think there's a need for all levels to kind of address the fact that we are living in a currently uncertain time where lots of people do have stress over and worry over the future of their jobs. I hear a lot of talk these days about toxic workplaces.
我认为这是一个很好的问题，因为我认为积极的领导和管理在确保有毒职场条件不会发生方面发挥着重要作用，特别是在充满不确定性和谣言的时期，或者当组织需要做出快速决策时。所以再次强调，我认为强调组织使命和价值观的领导力，强调支持员工的领导力，在组织中什么受到奖励和重视，并确保这与透明度、公平、创新以及我们在思考时考虑的所有这些目标保持一致。当我们想到良好且强大的组织时。有时在实践中，它并不总是能完全体现出来。
And I think that term has a very specific meaning. What constitutes a toxic workplace and how can employers guard against creating those conditions? So when I think of a toxic workplace, I think of a workplace sort of defined by fear, or fear is defining the defining aspect of the interpersonal relationships in the workplace. It's a defining aspect of the culture. It's a defining aspect of really. how policies and practices are implemented and executed. So how can employers guard up against creating toxic workplaces?
未必能以人们在原则上思考的那样呈现。但我认为，清醒地认识到文化是什么，并努力建立一种积极的文化（希望它是一种积极的文化），当组织和个人经历不确定时期时，这可以成为一个强大的基础平台，这一点非常重要。也许现在问这个还为时过早，但我还是要问。我在华盛顿，当然，我们所有人都对发生的事情感到一阵忙乱。政府效率部（Department of Governmental Efficiency）一直在大刀阔斧地裁员。
I think it's a great question because I think there is a role for active leadership and management in making sure that toxic workplace conditions don't occur, especially in times of uncertainty and rumor or when organizations need to make rapid decisions. So again, here I think that leadership that emphasizes the missions and the value of the organization, leadership that emphasizes support for workers, what is rewarded and valued in the organization and making sure that's consistent with goals of transparency and fairness and innovation and all those things that we think about. We think about sort of good and strong organizations. Sometimes in practice, it doesn't always come through.
所以我们在华盛顿确实在个人层面上看到了这一点。但这又是如何渗透到整个大世界中去的呢？除了华盛顿或拥有大量联邦员工的大城市中心之外，你是否在其他地方看到了影响？当然。是的，我认为我们看到了这一点。我们正在进行一些持续的研究，因为同样，人们对正在发生的事情以及对确定性和稳定性的潜在威胁有着清醒的认识。因此，即使他们不是受雇于政府，这也表明对稳定性和确定性的潜在威胁可能会随之而来。因此，特别是在政府的不确定性方面，假设高性能等前提下，政府工作通常被视为相对安全的。因此，我认为人们也在进行一种广泛的意义建构，关于这到底意味着什么？
necessarily the way people think about it in principle. But I think being very conscious of what the culture is and making sure that a culture, hopefully it's a positive one, but trying to build a positive culture that can be a strong kind of grounding board as organizations and individuals go through times of uncertainty is important. Maybe it's too soon to ask this, but I'll ask it anyway. So I'm in Washington, and of course, we're all in a tizzy over what's been happening. The Department of Governmental Efficiency has been eliminating jobs right and left.
这对于工作安全感或职业生涯的假设意味着什么？工作安全感真的还存在吗？因此，我认为你会看到那种将持续一段时间的连锁反应。你知道，几年前，大家热议的话题是疫情及其对职场的影响。你们现在还在看到其带来的余波吗？因此，我认为可能在两个方面存在余波。一个是回到不仅对整体工作的问题，而且还有对工作各个组成部分稳定性的问题。因此，当我们走出
So we're really seeing it on an individual level here in Washington. But how is that trickling out into the world at large? Are you seeing impacts in other places besides Washington or centers of big cities where there are a lot of federal workers? Sure. Yeah, I think we see that. We're seeing some ongoing research because, again, people are cognizant of what's going on and potential threats to certainty and stability. And so even if they're not employed by the government, it suggests that there's potential threats to stability and certainty that might come down the pipeline. So particularly with the government uncertainty, government jobs have typically been viewed as relatively secure, assuming high level performance, et cetera. And so there's also this sort of sense making that is occurring, I think, quite broadly about what does this mean?
疫情，毫无疑问出现了一些关于重返办公室的问题，你知道，这对人们的工作和工作意味着什么。这里面存在不确定性。所以我认为这是一种后续的不确定性。我认为，当人们眼睁睁看着就业系统在一夜之间崩溃并看到大量裁员时，也会产生不确定性。所以，你知道，我前几天看到一项民意调查，上面说如果有另一场经济衰退，80% 左右的人会担心他们的工作安全感，对吧？因此，失业不再一定是那个遥远的抽象概念了。这是人们可以想象的事情，因为他们亲眼目睹了。他们要么亲身经历过，要么看到他们的朋友和邻居经历过，要么看到了一份新工作。他们看到了新的一条。
What does this mean about assumptions of job security or careers? Does job security even exist anymore? And so I think you will see kind of ripple effects there that would go on for some time. You know, a couple of years ago, the big chatter was about the pandemic and the effect that the pandemic was having on workplaces. Are you still seeing fallout from that? So I think there's there's fallout perhaps in two ways. One goes back to questions not only of the job as a whole, but also, questions about stability of components of the job. And so certainly as we've gotten out of the
展示人们申请失业救济的新闻报道。当你把这放进可能发生的事情的领域中时，我认为这将在人们的脑海中继续作为一个可能性存在，并将真正塑造他们对工作和雇佣关系的看法。你的研究领域之一是职场中的人工智能和技术变革。你认为在未来几年里，人工智能将如何改变我们的工作和职场？这会发生得有多快？是的，这正是价值百万美元的问题。在某种程度上，人工智能已经在改变工作了，因为人工智能正在创造——即使它还没有在某些工作场所实施，
pandemic, there's been questions about return to the office and, you know, what that means for people's jobs and people's works. And there's uncertainty there. So I think there's sort of follow-on uncertainty. I think there's also uncertainty that's created when people have watched the employment system kind of collapse overnight and watched lots of layoffs. And so, you know, I saw a poll the other day that said 80% or something of people were be worried about their job security if there was another recession, right? So losing one's job isn't necessarily this far-off abstract notion anymore. It's something that people can envision because they saw it. They either went through it or they saw their friends and neighbors or they saw a new job. They saw a new one.
它正在产生大量的不确定性，关于它将如何被实施，以及是否会被实施。当然，我们看到公司在开发人工智能，公司在部署人工智能。我们也看到很多公司的人工智能项目以失败告终，因为它们没有很好地整合到职场中，或者它们在解决一些也许人工智能不应该解决的问题（你知道，人们并不真正希望人工智能去解决某些特定问题）。所以我想会有很长一段时间处于这种中间状态、某种谈判时间。有很多问题。所以我想这不仅仅是人工智能能否完成某些任务或某些工作。但这对人类员工意味着什么？这如何改变诸如地位、薪酬、团队协作、问责制、绩效管理之类的东西，
news stories that showed people filing for unemployment. And when you put that in the realm of something that could happen, I think that's going to continue in people's minds as a possibility and is really going to shape their views of work and of the employment relationship. One of your areas of research is AI and technological change in the workplace. how do you see AI changing our work and our workplaces in the coming years? And how fast is this going to happen? Yeah, that's the million dollar question right there. So in some ways, AI is already changing work because AI is creating, even if it's not implemented in certain works bases yet,
所有这些工作的系统、结构和机构？因此，随着许多公司开始试水，员工对此做出反应并观察这项技术如何才能真正发挥作用或被使用，你会看到许多向前、向后、向侧面的发展。你提到过有一些失误。公司尝试过人工智能但完全偏离目标且没有奏效的领域有哪些？
it's creating a lot of uncertainty about how it's going to be implemented, whether it's going to be implemented. Certainly, we're seeing companies developing AI, companies deploying AI. We're also seeing a lot of company AI projects fail because they're not being well integrated into the workplace or they're solving issues that maybe AI shouldn't, you know, people don't really want AI to solve certain issues. So I think there's going to be a lot of time that that's sort of kind of in-between, sort of negotiation time. There are a lot of questions. So I think it's not, can AI just do certain tasks or certain jobs? But what does that mean for the human workers? How does that change things like status, pay, teaming, accountability, performance management,
所以我想这里有很多例子，但是，而且我想当它们作为人工智能产生幻觉或类似事情的新闻被报道出来时，我们往往会看到它们。不幸的是，人工智能的好坏完全取决于训练它的数据。如果底层数据存在问题，那么人工智能的产出就不会好。关于人们在多大程度上应该依赖人工智能的推荐与人类决策，也存在许多问题。而且我认为在不同的公司和组织中发生的事情是，目前人工智能项目仍然非常昂贵。所以问题是，附加价值是什么？然后是对你的人类劳动力的影响是什么，因为人类是组织的命脉、竞争优势和人才所在？所以我想所有这些
all of the systems and structures and institutions of work? So I think you're going to see a lot of forward movement, backward movement, sideways movement, as a lot of companies start toying with us, workers kind of react to it and see how this technology can actually be helpful or be used. You mentioned that there have been some missteps. What are some of the areas where companies have tried AI and just been off base and it hasn't worked?
诸如此类的问题目前都非常非常悬而未决。那么你在研究技术吗？你也在研究机器人技术以及它将如何在职场中发挥作用吗？是的，是的，我们是的。我们有一些项目与服务机器人合作，研究服务机器人如何影响酒店业，以及员工和顾客对服务机器人的反应如何。其中一件有趣的事情是
So I think there's quite a few examples here, but, and I think we tend to see them when they come out in the news about AI hallucinating or things like that. Unfortunately, AI is also only as good as the data it's trained on. And if there are issues in the underlying data, then the output of AI is not going to be great. There's also a number of questions about the extent to which people should rely. on recommendation from AI versus human decision making. And I think what's happening in different companies and organizations is right now AI projects are still very expensive. And so the question is, what's the value add? And then what's the impact on your human workforce, which humans are the lifeblood and competitive advantage of organizations and talents? So I think all of these
我们发现，对技术的反应不一定总是基于技术本身，实际上也基于技术进入的环境。人们为引入这项技术做好了多好的准备？他们是否理解为什么要引入这项技术，他们是否思考过将如何转变他们的工作角色并利用这项技术来帮助解决问题。因此，我认为这是一个非常有趣的时期，但我也认为这是一个领导和管理将变得非常重要的时期，因为这些技术正在问世。它们正在被使用。问题是，是否存在一个能够帮助人们适应它们的背景？
kind of questions are really, really up in the air at the moment. And then you're looking at technology. Are you looking at robotics as well and how that is going to be playing a role in the workplace? Yes, yes, we are. We've had a few projects working with service robots, looking at how service robots are impacting the hospitality sector and how people, workers and customers are responding to the service robots. And one of the interesting things that
是否存在一个背景，让这些技术真正被用来帮助人类而不是取代人类工作？最近我听到有人说，这已经不是人工智能是否会取代我们的问题，而是那些被取代的人将是那些不懂得如何使用人工智能的人。你也是这种观点吗？我不知道。我想我会说我是持这种观点的。
we find is the reactions to the technology are not necessarily always based on the technology itself, but they're actually also based on just the environment which the technology is coming into. So how well prepared are people to bring in this technology? Do they understand why this technology is even being brought in, how they thought about how they're going to shift their work roles and use this technology to help solve problems. And so I think it's a really interesting time, but I think it's also a time where leadership and management is going to matter a whole lot because these technologies are coming out. They're being used. And the question is, is there a backdrop that's going to help people adapt them?
使人类变得特殊和独特的品质——同理心、理解语境以及语境如何改变事物的能力——这些将继续成为人们所需求的特征和品质，那些能够从人类和人工智能团队的产出中提取并真正弄清楚该用它做什么以及它意味着什么的人。那些具备领导力以及真正的人类技能的人。我认为，在技术和人工智能的新时代，这些人将是最成功的。是什么让你对心理学的这一方面首先产生兴趣的？当然。因此，我是在大衰退（Great Recession）之后完成研究生训练的。
And is there a backdrop where these technologies are going to be really used to help people rather than replace human work? And I've heard some people say lately that it's not a question of whether AI will replace us, but the people who get replaced are the people who won't understand how to use AI. Are you of that opinion as well? I don't know. I think I would say that I'm of the opinion. of that, the qualities that make humans special and unique, the empathy, the ability to
所以我真的对人们如何应对不确定性、经济不确定性、工作不安全感以及裁员之类的事情很感兴趣。但我也对人们如何适应和应对变化非常感兴趣。而且我认为我们在整个心理学文献中看到，有大量证据表明，虽然，是的，存在与不确定性和变化相关的重大压力源，但人类也具备非凡的适应能力、展现韧性的能力，以及为问题想出真正创造性解决方案的能力。因此，这确实让我对理解以下内容产生了兴趣：工作中的变化如何影响人们，
understand context and how context changes things, those are going to be that characteristics and qualities of people that will continue to be in demand, the people who can take output from a team of humans and AIs and figure out really what to do with it and what it means. that people have kind of leadership and really human skills. Those are the folks who I think will be the most successful in this new age of technology and AI. What got you interested in this aspect of psychology to begin with? Sure. So I finished my graduate training coming out of the Great Recession.
以及人们如何影响工作中的变化。又是一个不公平的问题，但我还是要问，因为这就是我的风格。如果你必须预测 10 年后技术将如何改变职场，你认为我们会在哪里看到最大的变化？另外，能不能有人创造一些人工智能来帮我控制我的邮箱？对。我也面临同样的挑战。人工智能被誉为这项了不起的功能。
So I was really interested in how people were dealing with uncertainty and economic uncertainty, job and security. and layoffs and things like that. But I've also been very interested in how people adapt and cope with change. And I think we see across the psychology literature, just a lot of evidence that while, yes, there's major stressors connected with uncertainty and change, there's also a remarkable ability for humans to adapt, to demonstrate resilience and to come up with just really creative solutions for problems. So that really got me interested in understanding, you know, how changes at work impact people,
但是是的，我很乐意让一个人工智能来管理我的邮箱和日程表。那将是，我的意思是，最有用不过了。所以，好吧，俗话说，预测很难，尤其是关于未来的预测，因为未来是无法预测的。所以我想我往往是一个中间派。我不认为一切都会变成人工智能，但我也不认为什么都不会变成人工智能。因此，我认为人工智能产生最大影响的地方可能主要是在入门级工作。而且我认为这些工作将不得不改变。我还认为你会看到更大比例的劳动力。
but also how people are impacting changes at work. Another unfair question, but I'll ask it anyway, because that's what I do. If you had to predict in 10 years how technology would change workplaces, where do you think we'll see the biggest changes? And could somebody please create some AI that will control my email box? Right. I have the same challenge. AI is hailed as this amazing capability.
本质上是在承担管理职位，因为他们将不得不评估人工智能的产出，监控人工智能的产出，并根据人工智能的产出做出决策。所以我想，是的，你会拥有一些需要重新学习技能并学会如何使用人工智能的劳动者，但我认为你最终会拥有这样的劳动者：他们将重新学习技能并学习管理和领导力的各种工具，以了解如何处理这项技术产生的内容，从而知道这项技术的决策或产出什么时候是好的或有用的。这就是我所看到的。再次强调，我认为会有一些前进一步，后退一步的过程，看着这一切的发展将会非常有趣。但这就是我给出的中间派回答。那么你现在在做什么？你试图解答的重大问题是什么？所以目前我正在和来自温哥华华盛顿大学的同事塔里尔·弗罗普斯（Tahrir Phropes）合作写一本书，我们正试图
But yes, I would love someone to AI to manage my email on my calendar. That would be, I mean, most useful. So, right, the saying is predictions are hard, especially about the future where they're impossible. So I guess I tend to be a middle of the road person. I don't think everything will be AI, but I don't think nothing will be AI either. And so where I think AI is going to have an impact probably most is probably entry level work. And I think those jobs are going to have to change. I also think you're going to see a larger proportion of the workforce that are. essentially taking on managerial positions because they're going to have to be evaluating the output of AI and monitoring the output of AI and making decisions based on the output of AI. So I think, yes, you're going to have some workers who will need to reskill and learn
将关于工作不安全感的研究翻译给大众读者。所以我们的暂定书名是《在不确定的工作世界中领导、管理与蓬勃发展》。这将是我在这里的重大夏季项目。除此之外，我的实验室目前正在努力理解的重大问题包括：继续理解工作不安全感和不确定性如何塑造职场环境、塑造人际关系、塑造人们的长期职业规划，以及塑造直接组织之外的结果，比如家庭和社区。我们还试图了解，当我们审视人工智能等事物时，对工作不安全感的反应与裁员或经济衰退相比有何不同，这些是人们经历的不同体验吗？
how to use AI, but I think you're going to end up having workers who are going to re-skill and learn various tools of sort of management and leadership to know what to do with, what's being produced with this technology to know when the decision or output of this technology is good or useful. So that's what I see. Again, I think there's going to be some steps forward, steps back, and it'll be really kind of interesting to watch what's going on. But that's my middle of the road answer there. So what are you working on now? What are the big questions you're trying to answer? So I am currently working on a book with a colleague Tahrir Phropes from Washington State University in Vancouver, and we're trying to
然后真正努力理解在不同的经济系统和不同的文化中，工作不安全感、不确定性和适应所产生的影响，并真正努力理解人类应对不确定性以及不得不适应变化的真实体验。好吧，肖斯博士，非常感谢您今天能做客节目。这非常有趣。谢谢邀请我。这是我的荣幸。您可以在我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org 上找到《心理学热线》之前的节目，也可以在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请关注我们并留下评价。
translate research on job insecurity for a popular audience. So our tentative title is leading, managing, and thriving in an uncertain world of work. And that'll be my big summer project here. But in addition to that, the big questions my lab is currently working on to understand is continue to understand how job insecurity and uncertainty are shaping workplace environments, shaping interpersonal relationships, shaping people's long-term career planning, and also shaping outcomes outside of the immediate organization, like families and communities. And we're also trying to understand how responses to job insecurity are different when we're looking at, looking at something like AI, for example, versus layoffs versus recession, are these different
如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以给我们发电子邮件，邮箱是 speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学热线》由莉·韦讷曼（Lee Winerman）制作。感谢您收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。在拉尔夫斯超市（Ralph's）享受更多省钱方式，例如每个过道都有的低价。当你下载拉尔夫斯 App 时，你每周都可以通过数字优惠券剪裁并节省更多。此外，你还可以赚取积分，在加油站每加仑节省高达 1 美元。在拉尔夫斯，每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。
experiences that people are having? And then really trying to understand the impact of job and security and uncertainty and adaptation across different economic systems and different cultures and really trying to understand, again, the very human experience of dealing with uncertainty and having to adapt to change. Well, Dr. Shalso, want to thank you for joining me today. This has been very interesting. Thank you for having me. It's been a pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review.
因此，每天通过节省和奖励来省下一大笔钱总是那么容易。拉尔夫斯南加州分店已超过 150 年。省钱金额可能因州而异。适用燃油限制。详情请参阅网站。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop.
如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以通过电子邮件发送至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学话语》由李·温纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。感谢您收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。在拉尔夫斯（Ralph's）享受更多省钱方式，例如每个过道都有的低价。当您下载拉尔夫斯应用程序时，每周都可以通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。此外，您还可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑节省高达1美元。在拉尔夫斯，每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。
So it's always easy to save big. every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. Seasite for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因此，通过节省和奖励，每天都可以轻松省大钱。拉尔夫斯南加州（Ralph's SoCal）150多年来一直如此。各州省钱情况可能有所不同。适用燃油限制。详情请参阅网站。本集目前尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。